we previously defined the cost function
J in this video I want to tell you about
an algorithm called gradient descent for
minimizing the cost function J it turns
out gradient descent is a more general
algorithm and is used not only in linear
regression is actually used all over the
place in machine learning and later in
the class we'll use gradient descent to
minimize other functions as well not
just the cost function J for linear
regression so in this video I'm going to
talk about gradient descent for
minimizing some arbitrary function J and
then in later videos we'll take those
algorithm and apply it specifically to
the cost function J that we had defined
for linear regression so here's the
problem setup going to assume that we
have some function J of theta 0 comma
theta 1 maybe as a cost function from
linear regression maybe it's some other
function we want to minimize and we want
to come over now algorithm for
minimizing that as a function of j of
theta0 theta1 just as an aside it turns
out that gradient descent actually
applies to more general functions so
imagine if you have a function that's a
function of j OS theta 0 theta 1 theta 2
up to say something that N and you want
to minimize theta 0 you minimize over
theta0 up to theta n of this J of theta
0 up to theta n it turns out gradient
descent is an algorithm for solving of
this more general problem but for the
sake of brevity on for the sake of you
know succinct ins of notation I'm just
going to pretend I have only two
parameters throughout the rest of this
video here's the idea for gradients then
what we're going to do is we're going to
start off with some initial guesses for
theta 0 and theta 1 doesn't really
matter what they are but a common choice
will be we set theta 0 to state 0 and
set theta 1 to 0 just initialize them to
0 what we're going to do in gradient
descent is we'll keep changing theta 0
and say the 1 a little bit they try to
reduce J of theta 0 theta 1 until
hopefully we wind up at a minimum or
maybe a local
so let's see what let's see in pictures
what gradient descent does let's say you
try to minimize this function so notice
the axes this is a theta 0 theta 1 on
the horizontal axis and J is the
vertical axis and so the height of the
surface shows J and we want to minimize
this function so we're going to start
off with theta 0 theta 1 at some point
so imagine making some value for theta 0
theta 1 and that corresponds to starting
at some points on the surface of this
function okay so whatever value of theta
0 theta 1 gives you some point here
I didn't initialize them to 0 0 but you
know sometimes you neutralize it to
other values as well now I want you to
imagine that this figure shows a hole
imagine this is like the landscape of
some draw c-pop with you know two Hills
like so and I want you to imagine that
you are physically standing at that
point on the hill right on this little
red node on your Park in gradient
descent what we're going to do is we're
going to spin 360 degrees around just
look all around us and also if I were to
take a little baby step in some
direction and I want to go downhill as
quickly as possible what direction do I
take that little baby step in if I want
to go down if I sort of want to
physically walk down this hill as
rapidly as possible turns out that if
you're standing at that point on the
hill you look all around you find that
the best direction to take a little
little step downhill is roughly that
direction okay and now you have this new
point on your hill you're going to again
look all around and then say what
direction should I step in order to take
a little baby step downhill and if you
do that and take another step you take a
step in that direction and then you keep
going you know from this new point you
look around taking decide what direction
will take you down hill most quickly
take another step another step and so on
until you converge to this a local
minimum down here here the dissenter is
an interesting property this first time
we ran gradient descent we were starting
at this point over here right starts it
at that point over here
now imagine we have initialized gradient
descent just a couple steps to the right
imagine with a nationalized gradient
descent with that points on the upper
right if you were to repeat this process
so stop at that point
look all around take a little step in
the direction of steepest descent you
would do that then look around take
another step and so on and if you
started just a couple steps to the right
gradient descent would have taken you to
this second local optimum over on the
right so if you have started this first
point you would have wondered about this
local optima but you started just a
little bit slightly different location
you would have wound up at a very
different local optimum and this is a
property of gradients in that will stay
a little bit more about later so that's
the intuition in pictures let's look at
the map this is the definition of the
gradient descent algorithm we're going
to just repeat the Li do this until
converging so we're going to update my
parameter theta J by you know taking
theta J and subtracting from it alpha at
times this term over here okay so let's
see a lot of details in this equation so
let me unpack some of it first this
notation here R colon equals going to
use colon equals to denote assignment so
the assignment operator so concretely if
I write a colon equals B what this means
is it means eel in a computer this means
take the value in B and use it to
overwrite whatever value is in so this
means zero set a to be equal to the
value of B it's its assignment and I can
also do a colon equals a plus one this
means take a and increase this value by
one whereas in contrast if I use the
equal sign then I write a equals B then
this is a truth assertion okay so if I
write a equals B then I'm asserting that
the value of a equals to the value of B
right so the left hand side that's the
computer operation
where you set the value of a to new
value the right hand side this is
asserting I'm just making a claim that
the values of a and B are the same and
so whereas I can write a colon equals a
plus 1/10 is increment a by 1 hopefully
I won't ever write a equals a plus 1
because this is wrong write a and a plus
1 can never be equal to the same values
okay so there's the first part of the
definition um
this alpha here is a is a number that is
called the learning rate and what alpha
does is it basically controls how big a
step we take downhill with creating
descent so if alpha is very large then
that corresponds to a very aggressive
gradient descent procedure when we're
trying to take huge steps downhill and
if alpha is very small then we're taking
little baby steps downhill and I'll come
back and say more about this later about
how to set alpha and so on and finally
this term here that's a derivative term
I don't want to talk about it right now
but I will derive this derivative term
and tell you exactly what this is later
okay and some of you will be more
familiar with calculus in others but
even if you aren't familiar with
calculus don't worry about it I'll tell
you what you need to know about this
term here now there's one more subtlety
about gradient descent which is
ingrained in descent we're going to
update you know theta zero and theta one
right so this update takes place for J
equals zero and J equals ones you can
update J theta zero and update theta one
and the subtlety of how you implement
gradient descent is for this expression
right for this update equation you want
to simultaneously update
theta 0 and theta 1 what I mean by that
is that you know in this equation we're
going to update theta 0 co 2 equals
theta 0 minus something and update theta
1 code equals theta 1 minus something
and the way to implement is is you
should compute the right hand side right
compute that thing for theta 0 and theta
1 and then simultaneously at the same
time update theta 0 and theta 1 okay so
let me say what I mean by that this is a
correct implementation of written
meaning on simultaneous updates I'm
going to set 10 0 equals at set 10 1
equals that so the basic computer right
hand sides and then having computed the
right hand sides and store them in two
variables x 0 and temp 1 I'm going to
year update theta 0 and theta 1
simultaneously that's a correct
implementation in contrast here's an
incorrect implementation that does not
do a simultaneous update so in this
incorrect implementation we compute 10 0
and then we update theta 0 let me
compute tenth one and then we update 10
1 and the difference between the right
hand side and the left hand side
implementations is that if you look down
here you look at this step if by this
time you've already updated theta zero
then you would be using the new value of
theta 0 you know to compute this
derivative term and so this gives you a
different value of 10 1 then the left
hand side right because you've now
plugged in the new value of theta 0 into
this equation and so this on the right
hand side is not a correct
implementation of gradient descent ok so
I don't want to say why you need to do
the simultaneous updates so it turns out
that you know the way gradient descent
is usually implemented we say more but
later it actually turns out to be more
natural to implement the simultaneous
updates and when people talk about
gradient descent they always mean
simultaneous update if you implement the
non simultaneous update it turns out it
will probably work anyway but this is
this album on the right is not what
people refer to as free ascent and this
is some other algorithm with different
properties and for various reasons this
behaves
can behave and slightly stranger ways
and so you know what you should do is
really implement the simultaneous update
of gradient descent so that's the
outline of the gradient descent
algorithm in the next video we're going
to go into the details of the derivative
term which I wrote I'll back didn't
really define and if you take the
calculus class before and if you're
familiar with partial derivatives and
derivatives it turns out that's exactly
what that derivative term is but in case
you aren't familiar of calculus don't
worry about it the next video will give
you all the intuitions and will tell you
everything you need to know to compute
that derivative term even if you haven't
seen calculus or even you haven't seen
partial derivatives before and with that
with the next video hopefully we'll
really give you all the intuitions you
need to apply gradient descent